- [Instructor] In this
video we're gonna use
a simple model for the
loanable funds market
to understand a phenomenon
known as crowding out.
And this is making reference
to when a government borrows money,
to some degree it could crowd out
private sector borrowing and investment,
and it could have negative
consequences for the economy.
You might have less
investment as a result,
and you could have less economic growth.
So let's see how the
crowding out can happen
using this loanable funds market.
So, just to be clear what's going on here,
horizontal axis, the
quantity of loanable funds.
The vertical axis, you have
your price of borrowing,
which is going to be
our real interest rate.
And our equilibrium real
interest rate and quantity
is determined by the intersection
between the supply of loanable funds curve
and the demands of loanable funds curve.
So what happens if,
let's just say step one,
the government decides to borrow
to fund some of its spending.
What is going to happen to these curves?
Is one of them going to shift?
Well, sure.
If at any given interest rate,
all of a sudden you have a big borrower
in terms of the government
that now wants to enter
the market for loanable funds,
at a given interest rate,
that's going to increase the
demand for loanable funds.
So the step one right over here
is going to shift the demand
of loanable funds curve
to the right, I'll just that
step one right over there.
And so our new demand for loanable funds
might look something like this.
And so let's call this demand
for loanable funds prime.
So this is going to shift,
shift the demand for
loanable funds to the right.
Now, what does that going to cause?
Well that is going to cause our
real interest rate to go up.
Real interest, interest rate
is going to go up.
You see it right over here.
Our new equilibrium, you
do have more loanable funds
that are being supplied and demanded,
that are being borrowed.
So this call this Q prime.
But you see this happening
at a higher cost,
at a higher real interest rate.
So we call that R prime.
Well, what's going to be the
impact in the private sector
of a higher real interest rate?
Let's imagine for a second
this first blue curve was
just the private sector.
Let's say that the government
just started to borrow
in this video shifting the curve.
Well, if the blue curve was
just the private sector,
at this new interest rate,
the private sector is willing
to borrow a lot less.
So we could say, private sector, private
sector
borrows less,
borrows less.
And so what could that result in?
Well, then, you could have,
and this is the negative
effects of crowding out,
you could have, because
they're borrowing less,
they're fueling less investment,
then you're gonna have less capital,
less productive capital that you can use
to produce things, so we could say,
less capital accumulation,
accumulation.
Which is just another way
of saying, for example,
people are investing less,
because they're not borrowing as much.
Investing less in factory
or some other thing
that might make people, or in technology,
things that might make
them more productive.
And so if you're having
less capital accumulation,
that means that you're going
to have slower economic growth.
One of the ways that a
country really pushes
its production possibilities curve out
or really pushes its long
run aggregate supply curve
to the right and has true economic growth
is through investment.
But if you have, if you're
borrowing costs are higher,
you're gonna have less investment,
less capital accumulation
and slower economic growth.